Earlier today I received orders from my superior.
I am being sent to investigate a mysterious
SCP located under a warehouse on the outskirts
of London.
It seems important as the SCP was just discovered
and the Overseer Council wants a detailed
report on it right away.
I pull up outside of the Port Superior Canning
Company warehouse.
It is abandoned, and from the look of it,
has been for a long time.
I enter the building and make my way to an
opening at the far side of the warehouse.
I descend the narrow stairwell where I see
a small black door.
I was told there was always a guard posted
by the door, but there is no one here.
I stop just outside the black door and look
up.
Above the door handle is a placard that says:
"SCP Foundation Department of Abnormalities.”
I am in the right place, but nothing feels
right.
Maybe I should just turn around and tell my
superior I couldn’t find the door.
I take a deep breath, grab the handle, and
turn.
The door doesn’t budge.
I step back for a moment and take a breath
of relief.
Then I glance to the side of the door and
see the sliding lock—my stomach sinks.
I move the metal rod aside and try the door
again.
This time it swings open.
I shake my head in dismay and walk in to the
other side of the black door.
I have now entered SCP-3790.
A series of dim emergency lights flicker on.
There are four doors.
On the other side of the hallway is an elevator.
“Hello?”
I say only slightly louder than a whisper.
There is no response.
I walk along the grated floor,
the metal rattles under my boots.
I can see through the grating and it appears
there are several floors below me.
I come to the first door and examine it.
All of the doors are identical.
They are made up of heavy metal, a sliding
panel that covers a glass viewport, and placards
that identify what is in the room.
All of the handles to the doors have been
broken off, and the doors themselves have
been welded shut.
It seems that whoever abandoned the Department
of Abnormalities wanted to make sure whatever
is in these rooms never got out.
As I stare into the room I begin to feel something
well up inside of me.
I zone out for a moment.
When I regain my bearings my hand has moved
itself to the spot where the door handle once
was; as if while I was in my daze something
tried to trick me into opening the door.
I immediately shove my hands into my pockets,
turn, and walk back toward the black door
to get out of this place.
Something is not right here.
As I approach the exit, the door slams shut.
I race over to it and try turning the knob.
It will not budge.
I have been locked in SCP-3790.
I begin to panic as my eyes dart from door
to door, scanning for a way out.
There is nowhere to go but deeper into The
Department of Abnormalities.
I glance down to my right and notice something
lying on the ground.
It’s a clipboard.
I pick it up and skim through the pages of
the legal pad that is attached to it.
Most of what is written seems like the ravings
of a madman, but on one page there are some
coherent notes.
It says: “Think it's about time.
Need to lock down the other sites before I
go.
Take care.”
There is a list of ten roman numerals with
either the word “locked” or “unlocked”
beside them.
VII, VIII, and X all remain unlocked.
I am not sure if this is a good or bad thing,
but it seems that whoever was here before
me is now on their way to complete what they
started.
I toss the clipboard and look down the corridor
hoping that a magical door will appear and
let me out of the Department of Abnormalities.
After several minutes I decide to explore
SCP-3790 more thoroughly; perhaps there is
another way out on a different level.
This gets my hopes up slightly, but part of
me believes this will be where I spend the
rest of my short life.
I walk back up to the door where I think I
hear music coming from.
I wipe the dust and grime off the placard
and read what it says.
The name written on it is “Vivaldi.”
I slide the panel away from the viewport and
look inside.
The chamber is completely empty except for
one object.
In the far corner of the room, a violin is
propped up against the wall.
In front of it is a broken bow.
I squint my eyes to get a better look at the
instrument; it seems normal enough.
Suddenly, an uneasy feeling comes over me,
like I am being watched.
I whip the panel closed over the viewport
and back away from the door.
I turn down the hallway and walk to the next
door.
The name on the placard for this room is “Montezuma’s
Face.”
I’m a little hesitant to open the panel
and peer inside because of what might be looking
back at me.
I take a breath to build a bit of courage,
and go for it.
I slide the panel open, and to my relief,
all that is on the other side of the viewport
is an empty room with a metal table in the
center.
On it rests an ornate wooden chest.
The chest has been secured with a large steel
padlock.
I put my face a little closer to the glass
to try and get a better look at the markings
on the chest.
I can hear a faint clicking sound like that
of a ticking clock coming from the room.
Other than that, all is still.
I shrug and check the next door.
To my surprise, the next room has had its
placard removed.
When I peer into the viewport the room is
completely empty.
This is strange as this door has also been
welded shut.
The fourth door in the corridor has had its
placard damaged, making the text on it unreadable.
I slide the panel open and look inside.
There appears to be nothing there, but upon
closer inspection, I see that the concrete
walls are covered in claw marks.
It looks like whatever was in this chamber
had incredibly sharp talons, and was not happy
about being detained.
On the floor are pieces of bone that have
had the meat picked clean from them.
Each room is another mystery but offers no
way out of the Department of Abnormalities.
My only hope is to go deeper into the facility.
I push the button for the elevator.
The door chimes and slides open.
I step inside and look at the seven buttons
on the panel.
Next to each one is the level number it corresponds
to.
Naturally I'm hesitant to push any of them,
but I know i’ve got to start somewhere if
i’m going to have any chance of getting
out of here.
I reach out and press the button for Level
2.
The doors slide shut and the elevator descends
deeper into the depths of the Department of
Abnormalities.
The elevator comes to a stop and the doors
slide open.
I step out into another corridor.
It seems identical to the first one except
there is no black door on the opposite side
of the hallway.
This worries me a little, but I continue on.
According to the placard on the first door
of Level 2, the room contains a man named
Ian.
I slide the panel open and look through the
viewport.
In the corner of the room sits a thin, pale,
man wearing a dirty straightjacket.
He is blindfolded and does not seem to notice
me.
His chest moves slowly up and down.
I feel bad for the man being cooped up in
there all alone.
But then again, I have no idea what Ian is
capable of.
The second room on this level contains something
called The Crying Boy.
When I look into the chamber I expect to see
a young child weeping; instead, there appears
to be a painting on an easel in the middle
of the room.
It has a sheet draped over it so I can not
see what is on the canvas, but from inside
the room, I can hear the sobs of a small child.
The placard for the third room indicates the
creatures that are contained within it are
called “The Watchers.”
When I look into the chamber, I see three
humanoid figures huddled together.
They are all staring towards the far corner
with their backs turned toward me.
The creatures sway back and forth slowly.
It’s an unsettling sight to say the least.
One that will be difficult to forget, and
will definitely haunt my dreams.
The fourth door on Level 2 has no placard.
When I look inside I see another dark hallway
similar to the one I’m in.
I try to force the door open as it might be
a way out, but like all the rest, it has been
welded shut.
I kick the metal door hoping and wishfully
thinking it will make an impact, but instead
I instantly regret my decision.
I contemplate my extreme lack of karate skills
as I limp back to the elevator in defeat.
I descend to the third level.
Room one on Level 3 contains something called
The Infinite Cold.
When I look into the chamber I can see that
the floor is covered with a thin layer of
ice.
What is odd is that the interior of the room
seems to go on forever in all directions.
It even appears to extend to the room next
to it, but when I look into the viewport to
the second room there is a solid wall between
The Infinite Cold and the empty pedestal in
room two.
I check the placard for the second room and
find that it is called “Sorrow.”
It looks like there was once something on
top of the pedestal, but the four finger marks
left in the dust that now covers it indicates
the object had been removed recently.
The third room is named “World Without Man.”
Unsurprisingly the chamber is completely empty.
The fourth room on this level is labeled “Adam’s
Hatred.”
This does not seem like something I want to
see, but I slide the panel away from the viewport
and glance in anyway.
In the back of the room is a large black mass
slowly oscillating in mid-air; I feel anger
begin to fill me.
The rage of this creature is palpable; it’s
being transferred from the black mass to me.
Scared of what it, or I, might do, I run back
to the elevator and hit the button for Level
4.
On the placard of the first room on Level
4 are the words “The Morning Star.”
All that is in the chamber is a rusted sword
hanging from the wall.
However, as I move my face closer to the window
to get a better look, the temperature starts
to rise.
It feels like the fires of hell are just on
the other side of this door.
The placard for the next room is labeled “Wormwood,”
but when I open the panel to peer inside there
is something obstructing my view.
I don’t spend much time here, and move onto
the next.
The placard on door three names this anomaly
as “Harmonia’s Necklace.”
Within the chamber, a golden chain hangs from
a post against the back wall.
A single candle burns just beneath the necklace,
illuminating the space around it.
When I look closer at the candle I realize
the chamber has no floor.
The light seems to be floating among infinite
darkness.
The fourth chamber on this level has no placard.
When I look inside, the room is unlit.
All I feel is a sense of dread - A feeling
that follows me all the way back to the elevator.
I descend to Level 5.
The first door is labeled as “The Heart
of Man.”
Inside is a human heart suspended in midair
by a wire hanging from the ceiling.
I look closer, and to my horror, I see the
heart is still beating.
The entire room starts to distort, my own
heart aches; I run down the hallway to the
second door.
The placard for this room has been pried off.
The word “hello” has been scratched into
the metal where the label once was.
When I try to slide the panel over to look
into the room I find that just like the door
itself, the panel has also been welded shut.
Whatever is on the other side of this door
must be truly terrible.
The third door contains something called “Channel
55.”
In the room there is a small CRT television
set under a dark cloth.
I can see the light from the tv shining through
the sheet, but cannot make out the image on
the screen.
The fourth door of floor 5 has a placard with
the words “Living Nightmare” printed on
it.
I pause for a moment to think if I really
want to see what is inside this room.
I figure I’ve come this far, and maybe it’s
just a trick to keep me from finding the exit.
I slowly slide the panel away from the viewport.
It makes a sound like a creaky door opening
in a haunted house.
In the room there is a bed resting on a metal
frame.
Someone appears to be lying on the bed with
a sheet pulled up over their head.
Creepy, I think.
I walk back to the elevator and cannot help
but feel I am about to reach something terrifyingly
significant in my journey.
One way or another, whatever is on the next
two floors will seal my fate.
I get off on level six.
It looks identical to all of the previous
floors.
The first room contains something called “Mister
Silence.”
Resting on the back chamber wall is a tall
wooden box.
It has been painted black with a purple “W”
adorning the front of it.
I hold my breath for a moment.
It’s so quiet that the silence hurts my
ears.
The second room contains “The Dead Man’s
Chair.”
In the corner of the chamber is a wooden seat.
There is no one sitting on it, but as I look
at the shadow against the wall there is clearly
a figure seated there.
I glance back at the wooden chair, but it
is still empty, and upon a second look at
the shadow, the figure is gone.
The placard on the third door reads “Ötzi.”
When I slide open the viewport it is covered
in ice.
I can’t see completely through the ice,
but from what I can make out there seems to
be a dark shape standing in the middle of
the room.
The fourth door on Level 6 contains “Apollyon’s
Crown.”
There are scratch marks all across the metal
door.
It looks as if something was trying to get
into the room instead of out of it.
In the chamber itself is a silver lockbox
resting on a table.
Whatever is inside must be very important
to someone.
I enter the elevator and press the button
for Level 7.
The doors slide shut and the elevator begins
to descend to the bottom level.
I know that if there is no way out on this
floor, I will be trapped like all of the other
objects in the Department of Abnormalities.
The bell chimes indicating I’ve reached
what I hope is my way out of here.
The doors slide open.
I take a few steps out into a corridor that
looks like all the rest.
I turn and gaze into the first room on the
floor.
Instantly, terror fills every centimeter of
space in my core.
It feels as if my heart stops.
Frozen in fear for a moment, I try to scream
but nothing escapes.
I come to my senses and am able to use my
legs again.
I run back to the elevator and hit the button
for the first floor.
As the elevator ascends back up to where I
began this nightmarish tour, my body trembles
more and more.
As soon as the elevator chimes at Level 1,
without hesitation, and with my shaking hands
and nimble fingers, I immediately rip open
the button panel and tear out the wires connected
to Level 7.
No one should ever have to see what is that
far down in the Department of Abnormalities,
and now no one ever will.
Now watch “SCP-5545 - Mysterious Tunnels
in Antarctica - ABNORMALITY.”
Or check out “25 Most Frightening SCP.”